pas
mark mahaney
ça pour votre fils c'est tout comme
j'espère que ça va lui plaire ça fait
deux ans que je n'ai pas vu
on à la mairie de moteur
aller où je suis sûr qu'ils avaient pas
menti
ce qu'il faut c'est survolé la zone
c'est quoi ça ben c'est un chien c'est
pas un chien c'est un ours et ça ne mord
pas sans blague
vous êtes le seul à pouvoir procéder si
vous envoie personne n'a dit vous dire
je n'avais pas le temps
le foulard jean cherche là je vous
assure l humour pain ban empêche je
préfère que tu la tâche
bien parti mais maintenant c'est moi qui
commande c'est clair mais je n'étais pas
des pièges et à partir de maintenant
c'est moi qui commande c'est clair